c'est une des grandes enseignes dont la
réouverture a ravi les consommateurs
avec le confinement de nombreux français
se sont lancés dans le bricolage pour
tromper l'ennui
ici ils peuvent donc se fournir en
tondeuse pinceau au tour de vis pour
peaufiner réparation et travaux divers
et variés j'ai pris en radio
est ce qu'il faut alors pour répondre
mais on l'a vu remonter à banos et un
prêt à nous qu outil confiance lorsqu'on
veut
les coupes assez précis qui ondulent sur
un poteau en bois pour pouvoir rouvrir
le magasin a mis en place des mesures de
sécurité drastiques paiement uniquement
par carte bancaire distance d'au moins
un mètre entre chaque personne et aucun
contact avec les caissiers ces
précautions semblent rassurer les
clients qui sont nombreux à venir faire
leurs achats
nous avons mis en place l'ensemble des
règles sanitaires qui nous était imposé
et voire même plus pour protéger et à la
fois nos collaborateurs tous volontaires
et aussi tous nos clients pour d'autres
entreprises la mise en place des mesures
de sécurité est encore plus simple
c'est le cas de saut promet talent qui
vend des matériaux de construction
destinés principalement aux
professionnels les clients passent leur
commande sur internet puis prennent
rendez vous pour la récupérer une seule
voiture à la fois est autorisé à entrer
sur le site soit les communes sont
prises par téléphone déjà encore une
transcrit sur un document comme dans le
magazine et avec la date et l'heure à
laquelle le client doit passer récupérer
sa marchandise dans ce cas soit prête et
qui parle me l'attend un temps trop
important un nouveau mode attente ces
précautions rassure les professionnels
qui doivent absolument venir se fournir
en matériaux pour poursuivre leurs
activités de ceux venus chercher trop
sacs de ciment pour pouvoir travailler
un petit peu je vais poser un peu de
carrelage et je suis venu chercher un
bond de 6,28 à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres le marché aux bestiaux
d'agents a de nouveau ouvert ses portes
le 22 avril dernier
accessible uniquement aux professionnels
il permet de mettre en relation les
négociants et les éleveurs de veaux et
de vaches tout marché aux bestiaux
permet de rassembler de l'offre
ar mais aussi de
les opérateurs économiques sur les
commerçants et les exportateurs va avoir
des références de prix donc il est
important que les animaux puissent se
rassembler sur un lieu commun jungle aux
moineaux n'est trouvé leur à leurs
acheteurs et pouvoir également se
valoriser à nouveau pour être mis en
marche et de ma mission
les négociants viennent de toute
l'occitanie les aussi de la nouvelle à
qui t'aident la réouverture du marché et
une bouffée d'oxygène pour certains
d'entre eux qui n'avaient pas pu
travailler pendant plusieurs semaines et
les reflets ça fait une semaine qu'on va
reparler
on peut rien faire parce qu'on n'avait
pas d'accord et on n'avait pas pour
garantir des distances de sécurité
le marché n'autorise pas plus de 100
personnes entrées en même temps dans les
lieux